It
doesn't make sense to kill
you on the right side of Nokto. Get the power of the crystal and become the true king.
I wondered if I was going to go home. I wonder if it was
the influence of Rei-san. It's
auto.
What are you saying
?
Tena dimm Especially, I can't go back to either one, why can't
we go through this? My
dad is a ruler
What does my grandfather die? Explanation Market What
happened at the dead auto?  It's not the sound of a typical painter, isn't it? I've been trying to
greet the war with the open white. The
cherry blossoms can protect the people.
I wonder if only the prince was missed
.
I didn't say
if I could protect it at the same time
, but I didn't say it. It was
a color that was sent out with a
laugh.
Hey, Izumi Yui
Goods Figure
All from the model in Taishi-cho, USA
I'm thinking of drinking a
tit too photo I don't think it's a escort.
I want to give you
the paper to protect this world
And now
I promise here I will take
pride in Nagi
to dispel the darkness from the political
world and regain the lost light The solitary
islanders worship God as a fun princess
It's the god of giving, is
n't it? It seems like you're in trouble. I
understand the barn.